and in short that's why i have to sleep
completely naked
well that's good to know okay so just to
remind everyone we're still on
amber alert following the poisoned water
attacks that took place in paris over
the weekend
how far is paris aside from paris what
else is going on joseph do we have a
systems update um yes uh not great i'm
afraid uh
two was already looking into who might
be behind it but we had an attack on one
of our own servers last night oh [ __ ]
tits
when exactly did it happen okay
please this is a test please take no
action what on earth are you doing
sorry i still get ptsd from my time in
afghanistan you never served in
afghanistan no i know but the drone
footage i saw was very realistic
how much data was compromised uh yeah
mostly alton's thoughts really uh
metadata from the middle server but they
did manage to capture a tiny bit of
mary's internet browsing history sadly
oh
damn please tell me none of that was
sensitive no
apart from i have been looking online
for a new
bra really what time well just a brown
one
yeah baby found him this is our hacker
[Music]
oh gosh what a dish sorry jerry do you
mind using less bad language
seriously [ __ ] is fine though isn't it i
say [ __ ] all the time
no you just talk [ __ ] there's a
difference
oh yeah no you have to let go sorry
this guy is good he wants hacked then
it's a database
nsa database really you know maybe uh
maybe we should bring this guy in and
make him part of the team
absolutely not i'm serious i mean tufa
used to be a hacker right
i don't know if i appreciate the term
hacker because i'm also a singer
the only reason tuva is here is because
she made a bargaining plea with the
government
in exchange for some highly sensitive
intel
please don't it was about the brexit
campaign what that was
about my point is we should keep our
enemies close
surely we can agree on that look give me
48 hours with him if it doesn't work out
i'm willing to take the hit on this
fine really why not i have complete
faith in you
looks like i'm finally rubbing you off
on me
finally ripping off on you rubbing
rubbing off on you
and finally yes yes that's the scent
you're rubbing off on me you wish
you